[Musique]
oh
on
on l'a beaucoup vu des personnes et qui
marche avec des morceaux de bois sur
leur dos avec et des personnes qui
avaient des enfants qui cultive et qui
faisait de l'agriculture et qui
travaillent et après l'avis des chemins
qui est qu'ils sont très dangereux elle
fait très peur parce que tu es à 10 cm
du vide tu regardes à ta droite il ya le
vide et des fois tu regardes à ta gauche
vu que ça des virages entre ya le vide
aussi et comme il ya plein de bosses ça
fait très peur ça fait penser un peu à
ma fac mais là on peut y accéder en
voiture part en tout cas pour le premier
les autres je sais pas encore et c'est
surtout des case en tôle
avec pas beaucoup de
la mi temps
[Musique]
et
c'est
pour moi beaucoup de fronsac avila
montrent un pas en compte dans la ville
veut y avait pas mal de gens s'étripent
l'attribuant à la montrent ainsi plutôt
qu'un aussi même niveau de la pollution
n'avait que dans la vie mais le fleuve
et à l'open d'échecs civils sont
magnifiques
avec les yeux et en soit ma crainte est
de près donc validé dans un petit livre
et ils devraient
on a fait 50 personnes et la plupart
entre des lunettes qu'hier c'est
vraiment incroyable de donner des
lunettes aux gens de voir leur réaction
est tous vraiment à leur sourire ce
qu'il y en a qui voient vraiment rien ça
change la vie
différentes europe en fait quelques
blocs mais je suis attendait un petit
peu pareil je m'attendais aussi donc
quand même quelques 4 cataractes des
fois ses murs des fois débutante et puis
quand même pas mal de ses sites et donc
il y latéral heureusement si leur permet
quand même de voir quand même dans la
vie tous les jours
je
à
[Musique]
qui
particulière je vais trouver
[Musique]
moi
essayez l'aquarelle villa et puis ça
leur plaît on dirait qu'ils essayent ils
prennent des pinceaux qu'ils veulent et
des couleurs et des tailleurs
corse alors que les salaires de s'amuser
et puis on est tous ensemble et on
partage des choses monsieur c'est pas
parler la même langue du coup c'est
cette
journée autour de la table saab est
sinon ça s'apprend s'implémenter
couleurs et ça tombe bien parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est la fête des
couleurs du coup ils le font ils ont sur
leur visage aux petits visages mais
aussi le mettre sur la sur leurs
feuilles c'est aussi génial ça montre
qu'avec pas grand chose on peut
communiquer on peut changer
il prendre confiance en nous voyant
et voilà on n'est pas un simple touriste
en partage
le
[Musique]